i
[Música]
desde antes de nacer deciden por
nosotros
deciden nuestro nombre nuestra forma de
vestir y vamos a comer y hasta cómo
vamos a dormir de hecho no puedes
llamarte mexicano si no dormiste hecho
el taquito
al ver esta imagen me acuerdo de una
frase rosso él decía que lo único libre
que tenemos desde que nacemos es la voz
así no podemos ni agitar las manos para
pedir ayuda con justa razón nuestra voz
es la primera forma en la que nos
hacemos escuchar así que desde que el
niño o la niña adquieren el idioma
prepárense porque van a hablar hasta por
los codos los niños hablan tanto que
cuando hay silencio aguas
puede ser señal de una travesura
o quizá
estén guardando algún secreto
pero como diferenciamos entre secreto o
travesura
observemos esta foto que les transmite
no les transmite ternura
no les parece graciosa permítanme
responder por ustedes yo creo que sí y
les aseguro que es la viva imagen de una
niña que no paraba de hablar pero guardo
un secreto
este secreto tiene que ver con un
problema que es verdaderamente grave y
seguir callada es igual a perpetuarlo
esa niña soy yo y estoy aquí porque
quiero hacer ruido para romper el mito
de que el silencio nos protege
este secreto los profesionales lo
denominan abuso sexual infantil
pero ver se sienten muy intensos antes
de continuar por favor cambien esas
caras respiren
porque las caras que necesitamos para
enfrentar el abuso sexual son de escucha
de empoderamiento y de empatía
urge que nos convirtamos en adultos de
confianza para acabar con la injusticia
y décadas de silencio lamentablemente
hoy en día existen personas que se
niegan a hablar del tema que se niegan a
escuchar a niños ya niñas que han pasado
por abuso sexual por la ignorancia que
hay respecto a temas de sexualidad y si
quizás si son temas difíciles de haber
de abordar
pero les aseguro que es mucho más
difícil vivir en el anonimato cargar con
culpa vergüenza emociones que no nos
pertenecen
el miedo y la lástima solo nos convierte
en estadísticas pues como dato que no es
curioso sino alarmante de cada diez
niños que son abusados sexualmente sólo
uno va a hablar en el momento que ocurre
los demás niños se van a quedar callados
por décadas o por siempre
si el abuso sexual infantil es una
realidad porque seguimos fantaseando con
la solución qué pasaría si esos niños
tuvieran un adulto de confianza por
experiencia estoy segura que se
atreverían a hablar a tiempo
es momento de ser historia de reiniciar
la forma de abordar el tema de dejar
atrás la ignorancia
y dejar de ser cómplices con nuestro
silencio pues no brindar información
también es quitarnos la libertad para
hablar
cómo hacerlo
con información segura
con la orientación de un especialista y
por qué no oí desde mi experiencia
quiero explicarles de forma sencilla
cómo podemos comenzar a ser adultos de
confianza
para empezar se honesto se honesta
contigo rompe tus tabús
actualízate en temas de sexualidad y si
hay algo difícil como un abuso sexual es
momento confía acércate un profesional
rompe el mito se piensa que al hablar
se hace vulnerable al niño que ha pasado
por abuso pero es todo lo contrario
cuando tú le das voz lo empodera si le
das control sobre su historia y le
brindas estrategias y autonomía para
defenderse
brinda educación sexual en el hogar es
ahí donde debe de comenzar por ejemplo
si existe si existen menores de 4 años
enseñarles algo que es básico pero
necesario el nombre real de sus
genitales pene y vulva otros nombres
pueden llevar a una mala interpretación
e incluso te pueden generar problemas
con la ley enseñarle al menor a
identificar secretos que valen la pena
guardar y secretos que deben revelarse
un secreto que vale la pena guardar es
cuando hay una fiesta sorpresa
y no se dice hasta el día de la fiesta
un secreto que debe revelarse es cuando
alguien te toca y te pide que no lo
digas ese secreto se revela
inmediatamente y por favor
eviten decir que la familia se ama por
sobre todas las cosas en casos de abuso
sexual por lo general el abusador es un
familiar según la unicef ocurre en el
75% de los casos yo soy parte de las
estadísticas tuve mucho miedo de dejar
de amar a alguien
que es parte de mi familia y pensaba que
callar era la opción
la tecnología nos está rebasando por
mucho que quieras que tus hijos e hijas
no aborden los temas de sexualidad
créeme en internet alguien más lo va a
hacer y de una forma no adecuada así que
asegúrate de que reciban educación
sexual en la escuela es ahí donde les
van a enseñar de acuerdo a su edad y
además crean un criterio para
identificar la información que reciben y
les brindas argumentos sólidos para
defenderse yo no sabía que el abuso
sexual y la violación entre otras
características se diferencian porque no
existe la penetración y en otro no y no
siempre se somete a la víctima con
violencia o amenazas como vemos en
televisión
yo pensé que lo que me pasó a mí y la
forma en que pasó no era tan importante
pero cualquier situación es igual de
grave y dañina si yo hubiera tenido
información estoy segura que hubiera
hablado desde antes sea asertivo sé
acertiva
muchos padres y madres aquí en mexico
acostumbran a utilizar un lenguaje
amenazante para proteger a sus hijos
la intención es buena pero no llega el
mensaje adecuado
mi padre alguna vez me dijo
si alguien te toca o te hace daño yo lo
mato
el día que a mí me pasó de lo que iba a
hablar tenía que defender a mi padre
tuve mucho miedo de que se lo llevaran a
la cárcel por matar a alguien recuerden
los niños son literales es mejor
utilizar un lenguaje amable claro
sencillo algo como si alguien te toca o
te hace daño
dímelo juntos vamos a estar bien y vamos
a encontrar una solución
ojo los cuidadores y las mujeres también
pueden cometer abusos no se trata de
vivir con paranoia pero sí es muy
importante preguntar e identificar cómo
se sienten los niños con ciertas
personas sin distinción de sexo o
parentesco
presta atención es muy importante
enseñar a los niños a identificar sus
cualidades
a socializar
a identificar sus fortalezas
esto también es parte de la educación
sexual y además les será más fácil decir
que no o acercarse y contarte
situaciones incómodas yo lo aprendí en
la universidad un poco tarde pero
nosotros vamos a empezar a tiempo habla
basta con llevar el tema a la mesa para
que alguien te diga a mí también me pasó
y eres la primera persona a quien se lo
cuento una cantidad considerable de
personas con las que yo aborde el tema
me lo confiaron como si toda su vida
hubiera necesitado una persona de
confianza para romper un hielo que
parece muy fuerte pero en realidad es
muy frágil
eso sí recuerda nuestra postura al
hablar sobre sexualidad debe ser de
reinicio de escucha empatía y
empoderamiento nunca miedo sobre todo si
estamos frente a niños
responsabilízate si piensas que el
cuidado de un menor le corresponde
únicamente a sus padres te equivocas el
cuidado de un menor le corresponde a
todos quienes le rodeamos y hay mucho
más por eso te invito a que hagamos
ruido informando no todo está perdido
aquí y ahora tú y yo podemos transformar
nuestro momento histórico un momento en
el que se escuche la suma de esas voces
y estás que se quedaron calladas de
aquellos niños y niñas que van a poder
hablar en el momento adecuado
estamos en el siglo de hacer ruido yo
quiero que hagamos tanto ruido para que
las familias se vean motivadas y hablen
del tema para convertirnos en esos
adultos de confianza
y para que por fin los tribunales y la
justicia escuchen
todo lo positivo que hagamos hoy por un
niño o niña que ha pasado o no ha pasado
por abuso sexual será de beneficio para
ellos para nuestras próximas
generaciones y porque no para aquellos
adultos que hoy guardan su secreto
recuerda la frase rosso lo único libre
que tenemos desde que nacemos es la voz
construyamos a través de nuestra voz
otra forma de enfrentar el abuso sexual
infantil hagamos ruido gracias
[Aplausos]